rues désertes à paris les voies sur
berge l'esplanade des invalides ou
encore le champ de mars sont interdits
d'accès seules quelques personnes
circulent coursiers livreurs caissier ou
simples habitants devront faire leurs
courses
réaction de parisiens sur le confinement
et sur les mesures sanitaires au micro
de cimetières lauvergeon et de nicolas
coupé bizarrement et heureusement et la
personne sur la route
donc ça fait un peu bizarre de de
conduire dans ces conditions après c'est
assez plaisant parce que j'ai des trucs
à faire par rapport à mon travail
moi j'habitais dans paris j'habite vers
le champ-de-mars je vis avec ma avec ma
compagne est donc le fait sortir un peu
ça fait du bien parce que voilà c'est
compliqué d'être confiné à la maison
avec les proches h 24 attendez que je
vis seul dans une petite surface c'est
vrai souvent besoin
rohmer mais bon il ya le fait qu il ya
les courses comme mon immeuble est en
travaux en face cumule tous les mecs
effect de gravité si je puis dire ça me
permet de prendre neuf mois alors que
des conseillers tous avouent des
attestations et tout donc lorsqu'on
envoie les la commande on met des voix
et la peau du client et ont appelé la
police
quand ils nous voient parfois il veut
par contre le groupe entend parfois
toujours maîtres de dix ans nous y'a pas
de soucis where he a toujours m
même chez les clients arrivés chez les
clients déposent devant la porte et on
s'en va on l'appelle le client il vient
chercher on se voit pas